moins chers collègues nous poursuivons
les travaux de notre mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert en
recevant cette fin cette fin
d'après-midi monsieur Augustin de
Romanet président du groupe Aéroport de
Paris monsieur de Romanet est accompagné
par Madame Amélie Lumeau directrice du
développement durable et des affaires
publiques et de Mathieu Kuip directeur
des affaires publiques je rappelle que
cette réunion est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat sur
lequel elle pourra ensuite être consulté
en vidéo à la demande
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
madame monsieur notre mission
d'information comprend des membres issus
des différentes commissions qui
représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat le développement des
filières de biocarburant de carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
représente un enjeu important pour
permettre à la France et à l'Union
européenne d'atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 mais
aussi pour notre souveraineté et
compétitivité de notre économie le
transport aérien compte tenu des
caractéristiques physiques propres aux
avions présents des enjeux particuliers
les carburants d'aviation durable sont
aujourd'hui au centre des attentions
tant à l'échelle nationale caniche long
européen un accord sur le projet de
règlement
refoule union
UE aviation vient d'être trouvé entre le
Parlement européen et le Conseil par
ailleurs l'hydrogène en tant que tel
lieu donne lieu à un certain nombre de
recherches et de projets industriels les
plateformes aéroportuaires doivent
s'adapter à cet enjeu j'ai pu le mesurer
très directement
en rencontrant vos équipes à l'aéroport
de Roissy Charles de Gaulle et je
remercie Mathieu de toute le temps qui
nous a consacré il y a quelques semaines
pour bien comprendre directement les
heures sur place vous avez également
exprimé des conditions très forte en la
matière il y a deux semaines dans le
cadre d'un partenariat entre l'aéroport
de Paris total énergie Air France KLM et
Airbus un vol Air France a décollé de
l'aéroport de Paris-Charles de Gaulle à
destination de Montréal en emportant
pour la première fois dans ces
réservoirs du carburant aérien durable
produit en France et incorporé à hauteur
de 16%, bien au-delà des cibles
actuelles ce carburant provenant d'huile
de cuisson
usagés a été produit à houdalle et à La
Mède
bio raffinerie que nous visiterons
vendredi puisque nous attendons dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône le communiqué de presse
conjoint publié alors indique que ce vol
concrétise l'ambition commune de quatre
groupes de décarbonés le transport
aérien et de développer une filière
française de production de carburant
aérien durable pré-requis indispensable
à la généralisation de leur utilisation
dans les aéroports français nous sommes
tout particulièrement impatient
d'entendre notre liste sur la
décarbonation du transport aérien sur le
rôle des plateformes aéroportuaires dans
ce contexte sur les défis auxquels elles
font face en termes d'adaptation des
infrastructures et d'approvisionnement
et sur la contribution du groupe
Aéroport de Paris à l'émergence d'une
filière française de carburant aérien
durable notre rapporteur Vincent capo
canelas à qui nous devons l'idée de
cette mission vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir kids
mais vous pouvez introduire votre propos
comme vous le souhaitez je passerai
ensuite la parole à notre rapporteur
puis à l'ensemble de mes collègues afin
qu'ils puissent vous relancer et vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
vous pourrez nous transmettre
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions que nous vous avons adressées
monsieur de Romanet je vous cède la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur
et donc vous avez d'ores et déjà répondu
par anticipation à la question que
j'allais vous poser du temps de l'exposé
introductif
[Musique]
que vous faire tous les modules puisque
les réponses à vos questions écrites
fait 20 pages donc j'aurais de quoi vous
ennuyer pendant deux heures mais je vais
vous limiter la 15 minutes certainement
pas de nous ennuyer mais non c'est 15
minutes mais si vous dépassez on vous en
donnera pas monsieur dromanes je veux
dire c'est que voilà on a on a répondu à
chacune des questions le la question est
très importante et existentielle pour le
transport aérien puisque chacun voit
bien que le transport aérien va avoir
une croissance tellement importante dans
les dans les années à venir que son
existence
va plutôt s'assoutabilité et
conditionner par sa capacité à réussir
sa décarbonation le premier point sur
lequel je voudrais insister parce que
c'est un point qui quitte sidérant au
sens étymologique du terme c'est que
cette question de l'urgence de la
décarbonation du transport aérien
extrêmement récente lorsqu'en 2019 on
m'avait demandé un article pour le
journal des finances investir sur la
décarbonation du transport aérien je
n'avais trouvé personne pour me parler
du sujet et lors d'une table ronde du
parieur forum en probablement en 2019
les représentants des compagnies
aériennes indiquaient que il n'était pas
question d'acheter du carburant durable
ça coûtait beaucoup trop cher les
représentants des compagnies pétrolières
disaient qu'il n'était pas question d'en
produire puisqu'il n'y avait aucune
demande
et donc on est passé vraiment pour
paraphraser Jack Lang de l'ombre à la
lumière en l'espace de deux ans
cette petite observation liminaire et
historique
vise simplement à dire à quel point le
retard qui
retard apparent dans
l'industrialisation de solutions de
décarbonation
doit être considéré à l'aune de cet état
de fait qui est que jusqu'en 2019 le
monde du transport en général
considérait que la dernière goutte de
kérosène serait pour lui
vous souvenez qu'on parlait du pick-up
il y avait beaucoup de crades quand on
fait que on manque de pétrole faute de
production mais les gens disaient bon
c'est pas grave le transport ayant de
toute façon il aura toujours du pétrole
parce qu'on le gardera pour lui donc on
est vraiment passé d'un monde à un autre
en 2019 alors ce qui est intéressant et
je n'allais pas forcément les clés c'est
de voir qu'il y a un certain nombre de
pays qui ont été plutôt en avance sur la
réflexion sur la décarbonation je pose
notamment à la Finlande avec l'émergence
d'une filière de carburant durable avec
une société qui s'appelle Nestlé qui est
de loin le leader dans le monde de la
production de carburant durable et
un certain nombre de fabricants de
constructeurs d'avions ont été sous le
radar depuis 2008 on s'en est aperçu on
discutant avec Boeing mais nous savons
que chez Airbus c'est tout à fait le cas
les constructeurs d'avion ont peut-être
été en avance sur les compagnies
aériennes et sur les compagnies
pétrolières puisque avant même
la question de la réduction des
émissions de CO2 elles étaient très très
en pointe sur les économies de carburant
depuis une vingtaine d'années on peut
considérer que un avion a économisé
environ 70% de consommation d'énergie
par rapport à ce que ce qui pouvait être
le cas je vous citerai simplement un
chiffre mais aujourd'hui sur un vol
transatlantique les avions modernes
consomment 2 litres et demi au sang par
passager ce qui par rapport à une
automobile est relativement modeste donc
ce sujet la décarbonation
il est relativement récent et les
aéroports sont en première ligne pour
encourager ce mouvement pour lui
permettre de se développer pour la
raison que nous sommes en première ligne
vis-à-vis des contestataires
c'est-à-dire que toutes les personnes
qui désirent la décarbonation ne vont
pas
manifester au pied des avions ne vont
pas manifester devant les compagnies
pétrolières mais vont manifester devant
les aéroports donc nous savons que
lorsque l'opinion publique
remettent en cause la soutenabilité de
transport aérien elle le fait
en s'attaquant entre guillemets aux
aéroports
et par ailleurs les aéroports ont
toujours eu d'abord
une vision de long terme puisque pour
accueillir les passagers dans les bonnes
conditions il faut aussi prendre entre 7
et 10 ans à l'avance quand on veut créer
les postes avions et des terminaux il
faut les concevoir c'est à 10 ans à
l'avance le temps de faire les enquêtes
environnementales de faire les plans
d'architecte de construire les terminaux
donc
l'ont des reporters voit toujours 10 ans
10 ans en avance
ce qui explique peut-être pourquoi nous
avons été un peu plus motivés que
d'autres secteurs de l'industrie et du
monde est rien
en soi les aéroports enfin en eux-mêmes
n'émettent que 5% des émissions de gaz à
effet de tout le secteur aérien donc si
on considère que le secteur aérien émet
3% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde le transport aérien c'est
0,15 donc c'est pas en soi matériel mais
ça n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
prendre le problème à bras le corps
alors il faut prendre le problème à le
corps parce que
nous sommes au début de l'histoire du
transport aérien
en 1960 le monde comptait 100 millions
de passagers
en 2019 jusqu'à avant le covid il
contenait il accueillait 4 milliards et
demi de passagers 45 fois plus
45 fois plus en 60 ans
et les prévisions qui étaient faites
avant le covid était celle d'un
transport aérien qui pouvait accueillir
9 milliards de passagers
aux alentours de 2040-2045
donc le rythme de croissance du
transport aérien était d'environ avant
le covid 3% dans les pays développés 5 à
6% dans la pire voie de développement ce
qui veut dire que 6% de croissance vous
doublez tous les 12 ans
et le point qui est sensible aujourd'hui
c'est que même si dans les pays
développés nous allons probablement
assister une modération des
comportements avec des voyages qui vont
croître probablement un peu moins vite
dans les pays en voie de développement
le besoin de voyagerien demeure très
fort en Inde on voyage 28 fois moins
qu'en Amérique or dès que quelqu'un
accède au statut de classement moyenne
son premier désir c'est de voyager une
fois qu'il est capable de se loger de se
vêtir et de se nourrir son premier désir
c'est de voyager et dans des pays comme
l'Inde en plus le voyage se fait
beaucoup plus facilement en avion parce
que il y a pas beaucoup de possibilités
de faire des trains à grande vitesse le
foncier est morcelé il y a pas besoin de
possibilités de faire des des
expropriations pour faire des lignes de
chemin de fer donc ce que nous voyons
nous en tant qu'acteur du monde
aéroportuaire
c'est que dans un monde où
au maximum 5% de la population mondiale
a déjà pris l'avion une fois dans sa vie
ou dans nos mêmes dans nos pays
développés vous n'avez qu'environ 10%
des gens qui sont des voyageurs
fréquents plusieurs fois par an
10% des gens qui sont des voyageurs
épisodiques plus une fois par an
au maximum et 80% des gens qui prennent
l'avion très rarement moins d'une fois
par an donc nous sommes confrontés à un
défi qui est que la demande de transport
aérien va continuer à être très
énergique très très forte et pourtant il
va falloir
des carboner le transport ail raison
pour laquelle
il va falloir trouver des voies et
moyens d'avoir des avions qui n'émettent
plus de CO2 et il y a trois possibilités
la première possibilité c'est l'avion
électrique
l'avion électrique sera probablement une
solution pour les avions régionaux
dès aujourd'hui une société américaine
qui s'appelle pipistrelle
annonce des avions qui sont disponibles
en 2025 avec une vingtaine de places
alors si à la fois une très bonne
nouvelle pour la décarbonation mais pas
forcément une très bonne nouvelle aussi
parce que ça va créer de la demande de
transport régionaux ces avions
électriques quand ils seront disponibles
ils permettront d'aller très facilement
de Cahors à Charleville-Mézières et de
Mazamet à Cherbourg ce sont des avions
qui seront relativement économiques peu
Pollo et donc on ne doit pas considérer
que c'est la solution de long terme pour
la décarbonation du transport aérien les
deux autres modes opératoires sont soit
l'avion propulsé par l'hydrogène avec
soit la pile à combustible pour les
avions de petites tailles soit la
combustion directe de l'hydrogène
liquide dans le moteur de l'avion
et ce sont les français qui sont en
pointe sur cette technologie mais on
aura l'occasion de revenir c'est une
technologie qui nécessite une forte
infrastructure dans les aéroports
puisqu'il s'agit d'hydrater les avions
donc d'apporter aux avions un hydrogène
liquide qui est d'abord conservé à des
températures extrêmement froides et qui
doit être acheminé à l'aéroport s'il
n'est pas produit directement à
proximité de l'aéroport c'est une des
questions d'ailleurs sur lesquelles on
pourra venir mais
on se disait tout à l'heure avec Amélie
Lumeau et Mathieu Cup en venant en
voiture que on a
une situation intéressante qui est que
au temps aux États-Unis on ne jure que
par les carburants aéronautiques
durables on regarde l'hydrogène mais
on considère que c'est une solution très
compliquée et donc on regarde les
Européens faits
et on peut avoir une certaine
reconnaissance vis-à-vis des avionsneurs
Européens qui sont déterminés à
transférer au transport aérien de
personnes la technologie expérimentée
dans le lancement de fusée aujourd'hui
on lance tous les ans des dizaines de
fusées avec de l'hydrogène liquide en
toute sécurité
évidemment transposer cette technologie
aux avions va nécessiter des efforts de
recherche très très important
et c'est à l'honneur me semble-t-il
d'Airbus que de se lancer dans cette
démarche avec de leur part et une
conviction et une certaine assurance
d'être en mesure de proposer dans les
années 2035 2040 des premiers prototypes
de d'avion propulser les projets
le Président Directeur Général d'Airbus
a fait justement d'observer que une des
difficultés au développement de l'avion
propulsé l'hydrogène c'est le fait qu'il
faudra un écosystème c'est à dire des
aéroports prêts à hydrater ses avis en
hydrogène et on peut penser que ça
mettra du temps parce que autant dans
les pays développés
ces équipements coûteux pourront être
mis en place autant ça sera peut-être
plus compliqué dans des pays récepteurs
de tourisme qui n'auront pas forcément
ni les moyens ni l'énergie pour à
Madagascar à sadomingue aux Maldives
accueillir des avions pour les refouler
en hydrogène donc c'est toute la
problématique de l'écosystème hydrogène
sur laquelle on pourra revenir et enfin
la troisième la troisième branche de
l'alternative à 3 à 3 volets ce sont les
carburants aéronautiques durables les
carburants aéronautiques durable se sont
donc des substituts au kérosène
qui peuvent prendre diverses formes je
dirais qu'il y en a quatre principales
vous avez les carburants aéronautiques
durables qui sont produits à partir de
matières premières agricoles
ce sont des carburants qui aujourd'hui
existent sur le marché mettons la
promotion n'est pas vraiment assurée
puisque ils viennent en concurrence avec
les productions agricoles et ils sont
très contestés par les
tenants d'un développement durable
ensuite vous avez les carburants fait à
partir de matière grasse animale ou
d'huile de cuisson usagée ce sont les
carburants qui aujourd'hui par exemple
sont utilisés au Bourget au Bourget on a
des stations services qui utilisent le
carburant durable de cette deuxième
catégorie qu'on appelle
hefa c'est sans doute que vous allez
voir à La Mède
et donc ces carburants à partir de de
matière grasse animale ou de huile
d'usagées sont extrêmement privilégiés
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis on a été
frappé par le fait que les Américains
disent qu'ils n'ont aucun problème de
matière première agricole et il compte
beaucoup développer cette
technique pour développer les
biographies la troisième catégorie de
biocarburant avant de venir
issaf il y en avait une troisième
[Musique]
des micro-algues bon je suis pas un
expert donc je ne développerai pas trop
et la quatrième catégorie c'est l'avenir
ce sont des carburants qui n'utilisent
ni matières premières agricole ni
matière première de graisse animale ce
sont ce qu'on appelle les
issaf c'était avec ce des carburants qui
sont faits par la captation de CO2 soit
la sortie des usines de ciment d'astieri
de de produits chimiques d'une part soit
dans l'atmosphère avec de l'hydrogène et
la
miction entre guillemets entre
l'hydrogène d'une part le CO2 d'autre
part permet de produire des ce qu'on
appelle des issaf c'est à dire des
carburants qui sont qui consomment pas
de matières premières agricoles
naturellement et qui sont entre
guillemets
renouvelable à l'infini
pourvu que l'hydrogène soit produit à
partir de l'énergie renouvelable
évidemment puisque si l'hydrogène est
parti et produit à partir de charbon on
est revenu à la case départ
et on en vient à ce qui au fond est le
cœur du du problème enfin il y a deux il
y a deux cœurs du problème mais si on
considère
que
l'avion électrique va vivre sa vie et
que les industriels vont développer
autant qu'ils peuvent les avions
électriques que l'avion hydrogène va se
développer mais probablement sur la
deuxième moitié du siècle d'ailleurs
dans une interview
à la revue Politique internationale le
directeur général d'Air Liquide
ou d'Airbus
évoquait l'idée d'hydrogène comme
l'avion du 22e siècle donc c'est
probablement pour en tout cas pour la
deuxième moitié du 21e siècle
aujourd'hui nous focalisons nos efforts
sur les carburants aéronautiques durable
les safs et vous savez que dans le
dernier accord intervenu au Parlement
européen le trilogue on est tombé
d'accord sur une obligation
d'incorporation des carburants
aéronautiques durables pour conduire un
montant de 70% d'introduction
obligatoire des safs dans les avions
européens en 2050
ce qui soit dit en passant et trop
faible par rapport à ce que nous nous
estimons comme devoir être introduit
dans les avions au regard de la
trajectoire que nous avons fournie au
gouvernement en vertu d'un article 300
de la loi climat énergie récemment dans
cette loi climat résidence nous avons
fait une feuille de route qui prévoit
90% 85 % d'introduction de carburant
aéronautique durable et vous allez voir
que ça à son importance donc pour
produire ces carburants en utilisant et
bien il y a un problème et un sol il
faut de l'énergie verte on estime que
pour 2050 la France aurait besoin pour
produire les carburants le monde pardon
aurait besoin pour moi la France la
France juste la France pour produire les
carburants aéronautiques durables dans
le transport aérien aura besoin à cette
échéance de 139 terwetteurs de
production alors pour vous donner un
benchmark aujourd'hui la consommation
annuelle des DF
pour la traction et pour toute
l'entreprise c'est 15 terwattheure par
an SNCF c'est Castle donc il faudra
l'équivalent en gros de 14 à 15 fois la
consommation de la SNCF annuelle
uniquement pour donner le carburant
durant des avions ce qui est une façon
d'illustrer le fait que nous avons deux
sujets le premier sujet c'est de trouver
les voies et moyens de produire ces
carburants durables et deuxièmement il
va y avoir une compétition entre les
différentes secteurs de l'économie pour
ces carburants durables on a observé par
exemple que les Allemands
avaient le projet de continuer à
autoriser les véhicules thermiques à
fonctionner dès lors qu'il serait
identité en carburant durable c'est le
cas par exemple des Allemands qui a
obtenu pour les Porsche les Mercedes
puissantes etc qu'on puisse aller
au-delà de l'échéance de 2035 dès lors
qu'une voiture serait propulsée par des
carburants donc et je terminerai
peut-être par là mon introduction parce
que sinon j'essayais beaucoup trop loin
et beaucoup trop détaillé mais le
l'enjeu pour la France aujourd'hui il
est de développer une filière de ces
carburants durables qui pour le moment
semble être en retard par rapport à nos
principaux concurrents
vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs lorsqu'elle
France a passé sa grande commande de 2
milliards d'euros de carburant durable
pour les 10 ans qui viennent ils l'ont
passé à des fins landais il y a des
Américains donc aujourd'hui de fait la
production française n'est pas présente
il ne revient pas dans l'analyser les
causes il me revient cependant de faire
observer que à la remarque des
industriels qui disent nous ne
produisons pas de carburant durable
parce qu'il n'y a pas de demande il faut
répondre que non la demande elle est là
la demande s'exprime maintenant haut et
fort et la balle est dans le camp des
industriels alors vous allez me dire les
industriels vont dire oui mais ça coûte
trop cher
je pense que cet argument peut être
réfuté pourquoi aujourd'hui dans une
procédé dans un monde dans lequel ces
carburants durable ne sont pas vraiment
industrialisés on peut dire qu'il coûte
environ 5 fois plus cher que les
carburants normaux
dans le prix d'un billet d'avion le prix
du carburant représente environ 30% un
tout petit peu moins 25%, on va dire un
tiers
ça veut dire que si demain matin vous
vous incorporez
10% de carburant durable dans un avion
vous augmentez pour donc dans ces 10%
vous avez 3% de ces 30%
qui ne valent plus 3 mais qui va le 15
ça veut dire que vous augmentez le coup
de 12 donc vous augmentez le prix du
billet d'avant de 12 %. est-ce que c'est
un drame
les deux années qui viennent de
s'écouler me conduisent à penser que
peut-être qu'on peut dire que non
pourquoi parce que la demande de
transport aérien qui est encore une fois
le fait de personnes qui sont
relativement à l'aise semble en première
analyse moins élastique que ce qu'on
aurait pu croire au prix vous avez vu
que depuis le début de l'année les prix
ont augmenté de
36%. malgré cette augmentation de 36%
nous avons un transport aérien qui est
presque revenu au niveau de 2019 en tout
cas s'agissant des vols européens ce qui
veut dire que
le fait que le coût du transport aérien
squata cru par la surcharge liée au cou
du carburant durable n'est pas un
argument que qui doit nous être opposé
par les industriels pour être frileux
dans les investissements pour produire
ces carburants durables
alors vous allez me dire
il faut il faut peut-être les inciter et
je crois que
à tout le moins les pouvoirs publics
européens seraient bienvenus de
d'essayer de prendre des mesures
comparables aux mesures que prennent les
Américains dans l'infection de réduction
acte qui est en réalité un plan de
soutien à l'industrialisation de
l'Amérique vous avez des dispositifs en
faveur des carburants durables
qui sont en permanence mis en avant par
les Européens pour dire vous voyez en
Amérique on nous aide et ils sont aidés
pas en France avec un million on vient
des États-Unis on n'a pas été frappé par
l'ampleur de ces mesures d'incitation
elles sont relativement modestes et un
dollar 25 par galon de carburant durable
ça me paraît pas finalement faire la
différence donc je pense que
symboliquement il faudrait que les
pouvoirs publics européens puissent dire
qu'ils font des efforts comparables aux
efforts américains pour bien mettre la
responsabilité chez les acteurs
économiques et vraiment les inciter à
prendre la responsabilité en prenant ce
tournant qui est indispensable
alors derrière tout cela il y a
évidemment la question de la source
d'énergie renouvelable qui va permettre
de produire ces safs et ça nous conduit
à nous féliciter de ce que
l'Union européenne est acceptée dans le
cadre du trilogue de reconnaître
l'énergie nucléaire comme une énergie
permettant de qualifier l'hydrogène
d'hydrogène vert hydrogène serviront
servant au safe
et donc il faudra faire flèche de tout
bois et au sein d'Aéroport de Paris par
exemple nous faisons ce que nous pouvons
avec les
l'énergie solaire
il y a encore quelques années lorsque je
m'étais efforcé de poursuivre cette idée
on m'avait expliqué que la direction de
la direction civile interdisait les
panneaux solaires sur les aéroports et
Bruxelles les pilotes
cette contrainte est totalement levée et
désormais nous sommes invités à tapisser
nos aéroports de panneaux solaires donc
nous nous y appelons mais on n'a pas
attendu cette autorisation on a été la
deuxième ou troisième entreprise en
France a acheté de l'électricité à terme
on a pris des engagements de 21 années
pour financer des nouvelles centrales
solaires qui en contrepartie d'une
garantie d'achat sur 21 ans à un prix
fixé à l'avance qui était d'ailleurs
assez avantageux parce qu'on l'a fixé en
2020 vont nous fournir 100% de leur
production
on a une unité qui a été inaugurée à
Caveirac dans le Gard l'année dernière
on va en inaugurer une dans le Var à
bras en juin prochain et dans les Deux
Sèvres
janvier 24 donc
je suis définitivement trop long et je
conclurai ce propos introductif en vous
disant que le
monde aérien
est conscient de ce que la soutabilité
de son développement passera par la
décarbonation c'est des carbonation est
possible
mais le monde est rien ayant commencé
plus tard que le monde de l'automobile
évidemment ça va se réaliser avec un
certain décalage cela dit les ingénieurs
du monde de l'aéronautique sont d'une
qualité telle notamment les Français que
je n'imagine pas qu'on ne puisse pas
relever le défi
et nous aéroport nous sommes
pénétrés de l'idée que notre rôle ça
n'est pas d'accroître le transport
aérien raison pour laquelle lorsqu'on a
mis notre raison d'être dans les statuts
en 2020 nous n'avons pas dit que notre
raison d'être s'était accroître le
transport aérien notre raison d'être
c'est d'accueillir les passagers qui ne
sont donnés
c'est à chaque passager de pose sa
responsabilité de savoir si vous voyager
ou pas et nous nous poussons pas la
consommation du transport aérien en
Europe parce que nous savons
et ça c'est du domaine de la
mathématique nous savons que l'atteinte
de 0 émission net en 2050
dans le monde passe nécessairement par
une grande modération dans les pays
développés et même pour ce qui concerne
le seul trafic français
nous devons avoir des taux de croissance
du transport aérien singulièrement plus
bas que ceux que nous avions avant le
covid si nous voulons respecter cette
trajectoire 0 missionnaire compte tenu
de ce que nous savons de la
disponibilité de l'électricité de
l'hydrogène et des safe
voilà ce que je peux vous dire en
introduction et maintenant je suis prêt
à répondre à vos questions pour
préciser tel ou tel point
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de Roumanie d'abord merci de
votre propos
vous êtes à la tête
d'un grand groupe mondial sans doute le
premier ou parfois le deuxième mais très
souvent le premier et donc votre parole
a du poids
j'observe une première chose c'est que
vous êtes moins pessimiste qu'on ne
l'entend parfois sur l'hydrogène puisque
on comprend l'actualité des
carburants pour la version durable on
comprend
qui est besoin qui soit besoin pardon de
mettre l'accent dessus mais souvent on
entend beaucoup moins du coup l'idée que
l'hydrogène reste une solution
peut-être pour le siècle d'après
et puis vous avez aussi évoqué l'avion
électrique
je vous en remercie parce que là aussi
c'était sorti du chant et notamment
l'idée qu'avec les pipistre très on
puisse
avoir des avions 20 places en gros des
2025 à la fois
et pour vous la capacité industrielle
peut-être à les connecter à fournir
l'électricité est capable ça c'est vous
ouvrez un champ qu'on entend rarement
donc merci
faudrait qu'on pioche ces points là
après trois questions rapides la
première c'est que étant atteindre
mondial qu'on vous comparez la stratégie
de décarbonation du transport aérien
comment vous voyez les choses comment
vous voyez la possibilité d'établir un
standard mondial et de régler tous ces
problèmes parce que ça ça nous ramène à
l'OACI ça nous ramène à un sujet de
réglementation mondiale quand même au
bout d'un moment
deuxième
point
sous une autre casquette j'ai eu le
plaisir de d'auditionner la directrice
de l'aéroport d'Orly et j'ai bien senti
la volonté qui est la vote de faire
d'Orly un démonstrateur alors vous avez
déjà un démonstrateur mais de moindre
taille bien que cher à mon coeur qui le
Bourget et là vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure que vous avez des biocarburants
au Bourget pour la mission dite
d'affaires
est-ce que il y a pas aujourd'hui une
possibilité pour vous de dire que la
dimension de démonstrateur d'Orly
pourrait vous amener justement à montrer
que on peut avoir des biocarburants
pour l'aviation sur Orly j'entends
parfois des des compagnies qui me disent
je paye la tireur à Orly et j'ai pas de
carburant durable
dans ce que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
qui était un peu l'oeuf et la poule
pardon c'est à dire il y a pas de
demande donc il y a pas d'offre est-ce
qu'il y a pas un moment une opportunité
pour l'aéroport de Paris de montrer que
là vous y arrivez j'entends parfois
certains alors vous me direz que ce sont
des producteurs
dans certains dont vous avez cité le nom
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs qui nous
disent mais d'autres grands aéroports
mondiaux européens fournissent cette
matière là et fournissent en tout cas
des carburants durable deuxième question
troisième question vous venez de
l'aborder rapidement là sur des
croissances et sobriété
vous êtes sur une
stratégie et vous l'avez affirmé à
l'instant
de grandes modération si je n'ai pas
travaillé votre propos ou votre pensée
est-ce que ça veut dire aussi que
quelque part vous allez du coup moins
investir en Europe
et comment vous allez gérer justement ce
cette problématique de d'investir pour
la transition énergétique dont vous
aéroports européens alors que le trafic
pourrait peut-être baisser
pardon
dernier point c'est que sur la
thématique décroissance et sobriété j'ai
noté tout à l'heure je me suis trompé
mais que vous aviez parlé de grande
modération du trafic en tout cas et du
coup je pose l'équation en disant mais
s'il y a une grande modération du trafic
en Europe est-ce que vous allez pas
moins investir en Europe du coup
et comment vous allez faire pour
investir parallèlement dans la
transition écologique de vos aéroports
et du transport aérien si il y a une
décroissance du trafic est-ce que ça
marche est-ce qu'il y a une équation
économique pour ça
alors s'agissant du standard mondial
alors bien entendu la question du
standard mondial se pose lorsque on a
rencontré les Américains on s'est aperçu
par exemple que eux sont très en pointes
sur le développement d'un carburant
durable qui est le moins émetteur de CO2
possible puisque c'est un carburant dans
lequel on enlève un savon de l'additifs
qu'on appelle les aromatiques c'est bien
ça alors quand vous enlevez les
aromatiques du carburant durable
vous avez un carburant qui est tellement
fluide qu'il faut refaire tous les
pipelines
parce que ça ne passe pas dans les
pailles pas une actuelle aujourd'hui on
a un carburant qui contient des
aromatiques et donc qui passe dans des
pack planes qui sont au standard
d'aujourd'hui donc ne serait-ce que ce
point là de savoir si on met ou pas des
aromatiques dans les safes ça vous
oblige à avoir un minimum de
coordination mondiale
par ailleurs il faudra aussi une
coordination mondiale sur le
recours à l'hydrogène comme je vous l'ai
dit nous nous sommes très actifs avec la
création avec l'air liquide d'une jeune
voiture pour régler un des problèmes
dont je n'ai pas parlé parce que je ne
pouvais pas parler de tout en
introduction mais que qui est celui de
l'introduction de l'hydrogène pour
l'écosystème immédiatement à proximité
de l'aéroport c'est-à-dire les véhicules
de piste les transports collectifs les
camions voir les trains vous savez que
dans les prévisions de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie dans son
rapport sur 2050
ils estiment que l'hydrogène sera
principalement utilisée pour les trains
des camions les gros engins donc nous
avons avec l'air liquides une JV pour
travailler sur l'introduction dans les
aéroports d'une alimentation en
hydrogène notre écosystème et nous avons
une petite société de conseils qui peut
aller de par le monde pour pour
travailler là-dessus donc
si l'on veut aller dans le sens de ce
que souhaite le Président Directeur
Général d'Airbus a juste titre
c'est-à-dire préparer un écosystème qui
fasse que l'avion hydrogène lorsqu'il
sera techniquement près de soi par
renvoyer au calendes grec faute
d'équipement dans les aéroports il faut
que dès à présent on travaille sur une
standardisation mondiale de
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène mais c'est
c'est la question que vous posez est
capitale parce que elle montre bien que
dans le domaine aérien la réflexion se
fait à 10 ou 20 ans et ce qui va se
passer dans 10 ou maintenant ça se
prépare maintenant
d'ailleurs c'est cohérent avec le fait
que les générations d'avions un avion ça
s'amortit à peu près sur 30 ans donc
les avions qui sont aujourd'hui en
circulation qui rentrent aujourd'hui en
flop pour une durée de 30 ans mais il
faut préparer la génération d'après sur
votre deuxième question
aujourd'hui les aéroports importants
sont alimentés par des pipelines qui
viennent en général de la vallée de la
Seine par le système du Trapil et à
l'heure actuelle on injecte dans le
carburant le jet fuel traditionnel du
carburant durable pour des proportions
qu'on estime
puisqu'on n'a pas les renseignements
détaillé cette année je crois que c'est
1,2%. donc on
mélange du carburant traditionnel et du
carburant durable qui va dans tous les
avions à hauteur d'un viol de chaque
année ça va être accru en fonction des
exigences d'incorporation qui sont
fixées par les autorités
la montée en puissance de l'exigence
d'incorporation je vais vous la redonner
elle est de donc 1,2% aujourd'hui 2% en
2032 non pardon ça c'est pour
l'intégration de carburant synthétique
dans les
dans les SAS
je vais vous donner des chiffres de la
trajectoire
si je les retrouve voilà à l'heure
actuelle c'est donc 2% en 2025
6 % en 2030 et 20% en 2035 donc à
l'heure où nous parlons il n'est pas
question de de réaliser dans l'aéroport
le mélange nous-même ça serait
techniquement très difficile
les moteurs d'avion peuvent tous
aujourd'hui accepter 50% de carburant
durable donc on a de la marge de
manœuvre quant à l'acceptabilité par les
avions et dès à présent des motoristes
ont testé des moteurs qui peuvent
ingérer 100% de carburant donc la
question de l'acceptabilité par les
avions n'est pas vraiment une difficulté
en revanche si on veut industrialiser la
Corporation de carburant durable dans
les avions il n'est pas possible de le
faire avec des camions qui viendraient
comme ça mettre un petit ajout de
carburant du rapport
l'effort sur lequel
l'effort Orly va faire pour être 0
émission net très rapidement va porter
sur
toutes les opérations du sol qui vont
être décarbonées tous les véhicules de
piste qui sont électriques tout le
chauffage de l'aéroport qui sera soit
par la géothermie soit par de la chaleur
fatale de la semarys soit par des
contrats de d'achat d'électricité
solaire et puis
un des grands axes de développement de
notre activité reportuaire et de
favoriser d'une part la connectivité
entre le fer et l'avion donc nous avons
tout un projet de modernisation des
gares à Charles de Gaulle pour améliorer
la connectivité
nous avons aussi un projet nous avons
aussi des nous sommes un peu des
stimulants pour
permettre de moderniser les équipements
de la Réseau Ferré de France pour
permettre au TGV d'arriver à Charles de
Gaulle par exemple aussi étonnant que ça
puisse paraître le petit barreau entre
Massy et Valenton qui permettra à tous
les trains SNCF qui arrive de l'Ouest de
la France et du sud de la France elle
est beaucoup plus facilement à Charles
de Gaulle et déterminant pour que les
gens puissent prendre l'avion en venant
du train si on veut que des TGV puissent
arriver à Charles de Gaulle le matin au
zéro les avions partent il faut réaliser
ce barreau massive Valenton que nous
promenons fortement et puis vous le
savez nous avons beaucoup travaillé pour
l'accès décarbonée à Charles de Gaulle
en militant pour la ligne CDG Express
qui va arriver en 2027 en 20 minutes
quatre fois par heure sans arrêt entre
la gare de l'Est et Charles de Gaulle
et puis nous aurons la ligne 17 qui va
desservir l'aéroport nous aurons le
barreau Roissy Picardie qui permettra à
la population d'Amiens et de Creil est
arrivé directement sur l'aéroport de
Charles de Gaulle donc si vous ajoutez
plus de TGV du C2 express de la ligne 17
de la ligne droite
vous aurez Charles de Gaulle qui va voir
son alimentation en passager
révolutionnée au profit du fer pour
contribuer de carbonner l'aéroport
s'agissant d'Orly nous aurons la ligne
14 qui sera mettra le centre de Paris en
direct d'Orly en 25 minutes
et nous avons un énorme plan
pour
je suis employer un terrain un peu
excessif mais faire disparaître
l'automobile de l'immédiat de proximité
de l'aéroport parce que un des grands
facteurs d'émissions de CO2 d'un
aéroport ce sont les accès en automobile
et donc nous avons un grand plan qui
vise à favoriser l'accès par
l'électrosports en commun et à écarter
les automobiles de la proximité
immédiate de l'aéroport
donc c'est voilà ces voies techniques là
qui vont être utilisées pour faire
d'Orly un aéroport
00 émission net avant les autres pour
les opérations au sol
au troisième question concernée la
grande modération et le risque de
moindre investissement
le point crucial et le suivant
le passage aérien est parfois
schizophrène
il réclame moins d'émission de CO2
et réclame toujours plus de postes au
contact c'est à dire que il ne peut pas
supporter quand il est dans un aéroport
de prendre un autobus
alors on peut le comprendre parce que
parfois le sous-traitant d'autobus qui
n'est pas de la responsabilité d'ADP qui
est la responsabilité de la compagnie
aérienne dans tous les aéroports du
monde n'est pas au rendez-vous donc vous
êtes dans l'avion vous êtes au large
vous attendez l'autobus ça prend du
temps c'est pas confortable donc
quoi qu'il arrive même aujourd'hui avec
un trafic modéré il va falloir qu'on
investisse pour créer des postes au
contact
et
notre vie quotidienne
est en réalité celle d'une entreprise
qui sait bien que son passager ne
supporte pas
les postaux large donc au fur et à
mesure que le graphique va croître à
Charles de Gaulle ou à Orly on va devoir
continuer à investir pour accompagner la
croissance de transport aérien donc je
crois pas qu'il existe de risques
énormes que les aéroports sous
investissent parce que
progressivement tous les aéroports
partagent la même préoccupation de la
qualité de service et donc notre
engagement c'est de toujours investir de
façon à ce qu'il est passagers soient
bien traités
maintenant ce qui est vrai c'est que si
les conditions économiques qui sont
faites aux aéroports dans les pays
développés
ne leur permettent pas d'avoir une
rentabilité minimum
égale au coût moyen pour des réduction
ce qui est aujourd'hui la règle de la
loi de 2005 puisque la loi 2005 dit que
pour la partie régulée il faut que les
aéroports puissent à tout le moins
couvrir le coût du capital on leur
garantit pas qui font du profit au-delà
du coût moyen on leur garantit juste
cela mais même cette garantie vous le
savez n'est pas forcément acquise compte
tenu un certain nombre de débats qui
peut exister avec l'Autorité de
régulation
mais dès lors que cette garantie serait
donnée je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
risque sur l'investissement
mon collègue Daniel salmon a dû nous
quitter pour rejoindre la séance
publique et donc il est en train de
faire des calculs alors peut-être
êtes-vous
plus prolixe que moi en matière de
calcul mental il me demande quelle
solution pour le transport aérien pour
se conformer aux préconisations du GIEC
qui dit qu'il convient d'agir dans les
10 ans parce que on a mis les choses en
perspective et merci merci de l'avoir
fait mais il y a comme une espèce
d'urgence
recommandée par le GIEC et je sais que
nos collègues écologistes sont
particulièrement sensibles au sujet
aussi
et la deuxième question qui me demande
de poser c'est d'avoir une estimation
des volumes de carburant
utiliser chaque jour
sur ADP je ne sais pas si vous avez ces
éléments là non parce qu'il veut
convertir ensuite évidemment cette
consommation en hectare de colza sachant
qu'un hectare de colza doit pouvoir
produire 1000 mètres cubes environ de
d'huile dont il fera ces calculs il veut
faire ses rations il me demande de poser
la question donc j'essaie de le plus
précis possible pour me conformer à sa
commande alors à votre deuxième question
je dirais de mémoire c'est entre 10 et
13000 m3
13000 par jour et 4 millions par an à
CDG
d'accord
en fait c'est la question la plus dure
pourquoi parce que lorsque vous
présentez une trajectoire à 2050 vous
êtes obligé de vous poser la question de
savoir si elle est linéaire ou si c'est
une courbe en cloche inversée
et une partie de la réponse
tient notamment dans dans la montée en
puissance des carburants durables dans
l'augmentation des prix et dans
l'élasticité du trafic au prix
donc
je n'ai pas la réponse à la question que
vous posez sinon que nous sommes
actuellement en débat avec les
constructeurs d'avions
parce que nous allons devoir présenter
une trajectoire de du transport aérien
d'ici 2050 lorsque nous allons présenter
nos prochains projets de travaux
d'importance dans nos aéroports et là on
devra donner la réponse à votre question
sur laquelle je suis pas en mesure de
vous répondre sur le siège que j'ai
encore des désaccords sur les notamment
l'élasticité alors
ce qu'on peut dès à présent vous dire
quand même
c'est que nos calculs nous conduisent à
penser que les mandats d'incorporation
qui résultent des contraintes
européennes devront être dépassés ils
sont aujourd'hui insuffisants pour être
congruant avec nos émotionnelles en 2050
et par ailleurs afin de donner des
garanties à nos parties prenantes
de ce que nous
faisons ce que nous disons nous avons
entrepris de nous faire certifier par un
organisme qui s'appelle
sbtianshative qui est un organisme
extérieur qui va vérifier que ce KDP
donne comme projection de ces émissions
de CO2 repose sur des hypothèses qui
sont vérifiées par des auditeurs
externes
et si je peux me permettre une dernière
question
oui la question les stationnements n'est
pas être complètement neutres du point
de vue du bilan économique du
fonctionnement des aéroports je pense
que les
stationnements sont aussi générateurs de
recettes et je suppose que ça avoir
quelques incidences sur l'économie
globale peut-être non
s'il vous plaît est-ce qu'on est vous
êtes filmés merci
Vincent c'est loin
oui
j'entends tout le développement qui est
fait tout le programme
ça représente des investissements très
lourds ma question c'est entre le
planning qui est fixé de la loi
le ces investissements est-ce qu'ils
sont compatibles avec les objectifs qui
sont attendus de la part des
actionnaires mais aussi des salariés le
fonctionnement courant de l'ADP est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce que vous vous avez le
sentiment que ces investissements sont
faits pour avoir une plus-value
à certains enfin bref est-ce que les
usagers demain préféreront l'aéroport de
Paris devenir dans l'aéroport de Paris
parce qu'il y a zéro émission plutôt que
d'aller dans un aéroport où il y a de
l'émission
Ça c'est ma deuxième question et
et
je m'arrêterai là puisque nos questions
sont limitées d'après ce que j'ai
compris merci
alors merci Vincent je pense que la
régulation française en matière
aéroportuaire est conçu de façon
exemplaire pour répondre à cette
question la régulation est
reportortuaire elle consiste à
considérer que pour tout ce qui est
indispensable au transport aérien et de
fait monopolistique c'est-à-dire la
construction des pistes la construction
des terminaux la décarbonation de
l'aéroport et
le respect des contraintes émises par
les pouvoirs publics à raison de la loi
ou de règlement
ça rentre dans un
montant d'investissement et donc ça
donne une base de capital qui ne doit
produire ni rente pour la société
aéroportuaire
ni
déficit au risque de d'avoir une
économie d'Arsenal donc le principe de
l'économie aéroportuaire avec le système
dit de double caisse il est le suivant
pour tout ce qui est commerce immobilier
etc les rapports fait son affaire et il
essaye de rémunérer le mieux possible
sélectionné
pour toute la partie qu'on appelle
réguler
les actionnaires ne peuvent pas attendre
un rendement qui excède le coût moyen
pour des règles du capital c'est à dire
il n'existe pas dans le système de
régulation française des aéroports de
risque de surentabilité de l'aéroport
aucun risque puisque nos prix sont fixés
chaque année par l'État par l'Autorité
de régulation des transports et donc le
seul risque que nous pourrons c'est de
ne pas couvrir le coût moyen pour
digérer du capital et pendant de très
longues années notamment pendant les
années covid nous avons eu des
rendements qui étaient très très faibles
et
malgré cela nous avons continué à
travailler
et pendant le covid nous avons montré
notre esprit de responsabilité puisque
plutôt que de se dire bon ben maintenant
on va on va augmenter les tarifs
maintenant que le covid sera terminé on
va augmenter les tarifs pour atteindre
un niveau qui nous permette d'assurer la
rentabilité du capital on a tout même
fait les efforts d'économie
considérables
des collaborateurs du groupe ont accepté
des baisses de rémunération temporaire
on a fait des économies de dans les
achats dans les toutes sortes de coups
ce qui fait que malgré le covid
nous avons pu proposer aux compagnies
aériennes zéro augmentation 2023 après
une année 2022 on avait augmenté de
0,94% donc sur les deux années 22 23 on
aura augmenté en moyenne notre taille de
0,40% par
an et pourtant grâce à tous les efforts
d'économie on espère atteindre une
rentabilité qui dépasse les 4% pour la
base des capitaux investis
et qui nous rapproche du coût moyen pour
des réduction qu'on estime plutôt entre
5 et 6%. mais donc ce système qui à mon
avis est intelligent
et vertueux garantit que nous ne pouvons
pas avoir de rente sur ce monopode mais
nous protège aussi contre le risque
d'être non rentable puisque la loi
dispose que le régulateur doit nous
autoriser à augmenter les tarifs dès
lors qu'on est en dessous de ce coût
moyen pour des rêves du capital je sais
pas si j'ai été clair mais c'est une
façon de rassurer le Sénat sur le fait
que nous ne rechignerons pas à faire des
investissements pour la décarbonation
Martine Bertin merci beaucoup
oui même si l'avion a hydrogène n'est
que pour 2040 avez-vous déjà pu évaluer
s'il y avait s'il y aurait un impact sur
les normes de sécurité pour vos
aéroports et donc des coûts
supplémentaires au niveau des
infrastructures c'est une question très
importante parce qu'effectivement
l'hydrogène est très inflammable des
mesures de sécurité pour l'usage de
l'hydrogène sont supérieurs à celles qui
existent pour le kérosène et donc c'est
l'objet des travaux que nous menons
actuellement avec l'air liquide
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que dès lors
que l'avion hydrogène verrait le jour ça
voudrait dire qu'il serait certifié par
l'organisme européen qui s'appelle le
hasard
donc ça voudrait dire que les avions
auraient le même niveau de sécurité que
les fusées ce qui en soit le défi de
l'avion hydrogène donc à partir du
moment où les avionnaires seraient
capables de produire ce type d'avion il
faudrait évidemment que les aéroports se
mettent à niveau pour l'hydratation de
ces avions en hydrogène et ça ça
engendra sûrement et surtout par rapport
aux pipelines généralement quelconque
que nous avons aujourd'hui puisque
aujourd'hui la plupart des avions sont
identés par des réseaux souterrains de
pipeline qui qui permet de se passer des
camions pour la plupart du temps
ma question était en lien avec celle de
Vincent Ségouin sur les frais sur les
coups engendrés par la transformation
alors si vous sont assez importants
est-ce que vous les avez chiffrées
est-ce qu'on peut connaître
ce coup de transformation justement pour
arriver à cette décarbonation et vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que le prix
d'augmentation de
vos compagnies aériennes étaient faibles
est-ce que le coût supplémentaire va
être répercuté
à l'avenir de manière plus importante
sur les compagnies aériennes et une
finition les clients qui vont devoir
augmenter sur les compagnies qui vont
augmenter le prix du billet pour pour
permettre
le coût supplémentaire de des travaux
que vous allez faire pour est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est le consommateur
au final qui va payer par l'augmentation
du billet d'avion qui va être lié à la
répercussion que vous allez faire par
rapport aux taxes aéroportuaires
exactement alors ça va être du deuxième
ordre c'est-à-dire que ce qui va
principalement peser sur le consommateur
c'est le kérosène et donc le coût du
carburant durable
ment pour la décarbonation de l'aéroport
ne va pas être excessif parce que dès
aujourd'hui nous investissons énormément
par exemple pour la géothermie pour
l'électrification de nos véhicules pour
le verdissement
d'ores et déjà on peut considérer que le
groupe ADP pour Paris seulement investi
une centaine de millions d'euros dans la
décarbonation donc d'ores et déjà c'est
dans notre montant annuel nous sommes
une entreprise qui investit entre 700 et
1 milliard d'euros 700 millions et un
milliard d'euros chaque année donc je ne
préjuge pas d'un impact sur le
consommateur
significatif sur le prix du billet
d'avion pour pour nous investissements
ceux d'autant plus que encore une fois
les principaux investissements ils
seront liés au coût du carburant de
substitution
alors ma réponse serait différente si
l'arrivée l'avion à hydrogène était très
rapide ici nous étions obligés de
recourir des solutions de production
d'hydrogène sur place
à ce moment là ça voudrait dire que
dès aujourd'hui nous avons réfléchi à ce
que pourrait vouloir dire la production
hydrogène sur place et par exemple à
Charles de Gaulle on a dès à présent une
zone de 40 hectares qui réservée pour le
cas où l'hydrogène devrait être
liquéfié sur place ou l'électrolyse
devrait se faire sur place
electrolyse puis liquide faction donc à
ce moment là effectivement ça
engendrerait des coûts très élevés mais
je peux pas encore vous en donner le
montant
oui merci oui monsieur le Président
Aéroport de Paris et que vous avez
l'honneur de présider et est exemplaire
j'ai pu le visiter il y a quelques temps
avec
Mathieu
je dois dire que pour être exemplaire
ça veut dire aussi que s'il y a 9
milliards de passagers dans le monde
c'est ça vous avez dit tout à l'heure
en 2045 ça veut dire que la croissance
des vols va être aussi assez forte sur
ADP
[Musique]
ça veut dire qu'il y a d'autres
compagnies que les nôtres qui vont se
poser qui et qui qui elle aussi doivent
être exemplaires et est-ce qu'il y a
dans le cadre d'ADP une démarche plus
collective avec l'ensemble des aéroports
internationaux pour mener la même
politique pour avoir le résultat parce
qu'on peut pas avoir le résultat tout
seul
un avion qui vient de je ne sais pas où
du bout du monde il va bien falloir que
il accepte aussi les conditions
d'Aéroport de Paris alors quelle est la
démarche votre démarche sur un plan
international je crois
que
s'est pris par la peau du cou et
l'accord qui est intervenu à l'OSCI en
novembre 2022 d'ailleurs grâce à
l'engagement de Clément Beaune le
ministre des Transports qui a beaucoup
poussé pour notamment que les Chinois et
les Indiens acceptent ce qu'on appelle
le Eltax c'est-à-dire le long terme
agrumante pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre le transport aérien
est en train de rentrer dans le rang des
accords de Paris jusqu'à présent il
était reproché au secteur ayant d'avoir
son propre système qu'il n'était pas
congruant avec les exigences de l'accord
de Paris ça n'est plus le cas désormais
avec les accords de l'OACI donc que ça
soit les compagnies aériennes ou les
aéroports je pense que tout le monde
aujourd'hui est consciente des efforts à
faire il n'y a pas de
il y a pas de crainte l'Association
mondiale des aéroports a établi un label
de décarbonation des aéroports avec 5
niveaux et chaque aéroport dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est bien que s'il veut
attirer des capitaux s'il veut qu'on
puisse lui prêter il doit acquérir très
rapidement un niveau d'accréditation qui
soit élevé et nous dans nos objectifs du
plan stratégique il y a le fait de
d'élever le niveau d'accréditation de
tous nos aéroports
donc
toutes les compagnies du monde qui
arrivent à Paris ou en Europe auront les
mêmes obligations d'incorporation de sa
monsieur rapporteur
merci Monsieur prudent monsieur le
Président des rapports de Paris tout à
l'heure vous nous avez
vous expliquer que il y avait toujours
la piste de l'hydrogène qu'il y avait la
possibilité pour des avions de moins de
25 places de développer l'électrique
mais que la priorité à court terme et je
crois que c'est communément admis c'est
en gros les savent en tout cas les
carburants durable donc je reviens une
question toute simple qu'on se pose
collectivement et on a échangé tout à
l'heure sur un certain nombre de points
d'étapes ensemble c'est à dire tout
bêtement il faut produire alors comment
on produit vous ne dites que l'objectif
va être en 2050 de 70% donc
d'incorporation et que vous vous fixez
si j'ai bien noté tout à l'heure
l'objectif vous d'être à 85%
du coup j'imagine que dans votre
raisonnement cette question là de qui va
produire comment quel volume à quel prix
vous l'avez vous avez commencé à la
modéliser alors mon collègue qui faisait
porte parole un peu Daniel seulement
commencé sur ce sujet là mais je dois y
revenir c'est à dire finalement
comment ça peut marcher c'est à dire que
là soit on est sur du carburant entre
guillemets verts et il y a un sujet de
d'avoir de la matière
début carburants soit on est sur des
safs et effectivement se posent par des
e-carburants pardon des fioules se pose
la question de potentiel d'électricité
notamment
mais comment vous modélisez tout ça et
ensuite comment vous pensez qu'on
pourrait créer puisque c'est ça l'objet
de cette mission d'information les des
meilleurs conditions pour renouvelle
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a un peu
l'impression que c'est la poule qui
regarde le couteau
et tout le monde se dit par quel bout on
prend le sujet
on entend parfois certains vous avez
cité le groupe Nestlé le groupe d'AST
lui il nous dit moi si c'est des
carburants durables des biocarburants la
matière je la trouve
et là on se regarde on se dit tiens
c'est quand même bizarre parce qu'en
France on dit le contraire bon et puis
sur la production électrique en
elle-même ça renvoie sans doute à un
débat public enfin des mais si vous
deviez nous dire pour assumer mes
objectifs en gros j'entends que vous
avez pas forcément tout modélisé mais
pour assumer un objectif a priori
raisonnable voilà ce que je vois comme
possibilité ça renvoie évidemment sur
les raffineries etc et sur les
producteurs mais en même temps qu'est-ce
que la puissance publique peut faire
pour pour qu'on y arrive
c'est la question est plus difficile
parce que
dans une économie de marché sauf à ce
que l'État décide de créer un arsenal de
production de carburant durable il faut
tout de même
faire entre guillemets se reposer sur
des acteurs de marché
si c'est à peu présente taux de ma part
mais je crois qu'on peut quand même dire
que il y a de la part des acteurs de
marché
un certain
frilosité qui a pu exister quand au fait
qu'ils se sont dit bon c'est bien gentil
on va investir pour créer des carburants
durable mais personne va nous les
acheter
donc
des mécanismes
qui donnent la garantie aux producteurs
de ces carburants durables
qu'ils auront un débouché pendant un
certain nombre d'années pour
rentabiliser leurs investissements
ce serait sûrement de nature à amorcer
la pompe
parce que au fond c'est vraiment le
problème de poulet d’œuf que vous que
vous disiez
je pense que les les
énergéticiens sont responsables ils ont
des chercheurs de talents ils ont une
responsabilité dans leurs actionnaires
et je pense que
il est possible c'est une interprétation
qui se soit dit que leur responsabilité
vis-à-vis de leurs actionnaires
étaient de ne pas investir trop tôt dans
des objets qui ne seraient pas vendables
parce que trop cher et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je m'épousonne depuis que
je parle de ce sujet depuis plusieurs
années à dire le prix n'est pas un sujet
le transport aérien est capable
d'acheter des carburants durables même
s'ils sont plus chers l'exigence de la
décarbonation passe avant l'exigence du
low cost
c'est ce que je
depuis plusieurs années et je crois
avoir été les premiers à dire que il
fallait s'habituer à ce que
malheureusement le transport aérien
coûterait plus cher parce qu'il faut
faire payer le transport aérien par le
passager et pas par le contribuable
néanmoins si on veut que le système
démarre probablement qu'il faut mettre
en place des incitations pour qu'il n'y
ait plus de réserve des énergéticiens
pour dire à leurs actionnaires nous
investissons dans cette
action qui a un marché derrière la
preuve qui a marché c'est que les
pouvoirs publics nous ont garantis que
pendant 10 ans
on pourrait avoir tel ou telle
incitation un peu comparable à ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis où il y a ces
incitations
monsieur le Président
je prendrai peut-être un peu la suite de
monsieur le rapporteur sur
sur la question de la stratégie d'avenir
parce que d'ailleurs c'est un problème
qu'on rencontre dans beaucoup
d'auditions où on a plusieurs solutions
techniques alors vous avez parlé de
l'hydrogène j'ai parlé des carburants en
additif au carburant actuel vous avez
parlé d'électricité d'ailleurs mais en
fait quelle est pour vous
quel est votre votre choix à venir
qu'est-ce que vous sentez en termes de
choix sur la solution qui sera la
meilleure par rapport à la décarbonation
la solution qui techniquement est la
parce que c'est elle qui génère le moins
d'entrepris et qu'il a plus efficiente
en termes de rendement énergétique c'est
l'hydrogène hydrogène oui me semble-t-il
mais bon je suis pas mais des
discussions que j'ai pu avoir avec les
uns et les autres c'est hydrogène et ce
que je j'observe très modestement c'est
que la France est le pays qui a inventé
l'aviation la France et le pays qui
dispose enfin l'Europe avec Airbus
puisque airbusier une entreprise
européenne est une entreprise qui prend
le risque de beaucoup investir sur la
vie hydrogène qui est probablement plus
ambitieux au point de vue technique que
la simple utilisation de SAF
mais qu'à long terme c'est probablement
la solution la plus économe en émission
de CO2 et la plus efficiente mais ce
faisant je ne fais que vous donnez un
sentiment
fondé sur une réalité physique qui est
l'efficience de la combustion
l'hydrogène pour propulser un avion sans
méconnaître les difficultés techniques
notamment celle évoquée par madame le
sénateur sur le les problèmes de
sécurité qui sont
devant nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui tout le monde se
précipite sur les carburants
aéronautiques durables parce qu'il
s'agit simplement de substituer un
liquide à notre liquide
mais si sur le long terme je pense que
la solution de l'avion hydrogène est une
solution d'avenir
[Musique]
non je réagissais à votre remarque là
c'est vrai que
les carburants durables on a auditionné
hier Margaux de Lahoud qui a une
expertise sur le sujet et je me suis
permis de lui dire que effectivement on
allait aussi vers les safs parce que
c'est une solution qui marchait avec les
moteurs actuels
c'est pas une rupture technologique et
que la vraie question c'est à quel
moment il y a une rupture technologique
comment on crée les conditions mais on
sent aussi qu'on n'est pas totalement
mûr sur ce point là et que peut-être que
l'avion du 22e siècle ça sera
effectivement l'avion hydrogène on peut
le souhaiter avant effectivement pour
les raisons que vous avez donné je
comprends bien que ça ça permet de
d'avoir une meilleure entre guillemets
efficience
environnementale on achète volontiers le
raisonnement après la question
c'est aussi de ne pas miser un de phase
et
d'avoir un système où on fait un pas
dans la transition écologique de l'aéria
pas significatif mais ne pas partir non
plus sur une mauvaise voie donc c'est
vrai que du coup il y a les safs et
c'est sans doute la première étape mais
j'entends de votre raisonnement je vous
remercie de ne pas renoncer à
l'hydrogène alors après peut-être ça
posera la question pour vous la
cohabitation parce que ça veut dire que
vous auriez sur un même aéroport à
certains moments peut-être alors soit
parce qu'on bouleverse tous les standard
et est-ce que les États-Unis nous
suivent et que fait la Chine aussi
là-dessus mais vous aurez peut-être à la
fois de l'électricité du kérosène encore
ou des biocarburants et de l'hydrogène
pas simple
les spécialistes pensent que l'avion
hydrogène n'est possible que pour des
distances relativement courtes terre
pour une distance de 16000 km entre
pertes et Londres là il faudra toujours
avoir des carburants durables
oui exactement donc on estime que
l'avion hydrogène n'est pas la solution
pour les très longs loyers aujourd'hui
un avion très long courrier peut faire
16000 km sans s'arrêter mais il ne
pourra pas le faire autrement qu'avec
des carburants durable donc de toutes
les façons il faudra que les deux
coexistent voilà d'où la cohabitation
juste une précision je comprends pas
pourquoi le prix n'est pas un problème
dans le prix le prix du billet le
surcoût lié à la décarbonation j'entends
dire que ce n'est pas un problème
pourtant nous sommes soumis même dans le
transparer aux règles du commerce au low
cost et on voit les effets du locoste on
voit et quand je dis que le prix n'est
pas un problème c'est parce que les
compagnies Low Costes vont devoir aussi
supporter les mêmes augmentations de
prix on a le choix entre assurer la
solidabilité de transport aérien et
payer le prix ou ne plus pouvoir prendre
l'avion parce que si on n'est pas
capable de décarboner le transport
aérien il y a un moment où un certain
nombre de parties prenantes de dire on
nous interdisons l'utilisation
de la vie et donc quand je dis hausse du
prix c'est bien entendu hausse du prix
pour tous les modes d'avion y compris
les low cost puisque aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs les low Costes sont assez
responsables un des un des leaders de
l'utilisation des safs c'est Ryanair
donc cette hausse du prix
malheureusement parce que vous voyez
surtout pas qu'on serait juste de la rue
bien entendu ça va contre nos intérêts
c'est simplement avec un esprit de
responsabilité que nous disons nous
préférons assurer la préservation d'un
mode de transport aérien ou ne
contraigne pas les gens à deux vols dans
une vie ou quatre volts dans une vie
comme certains le disent
certains le disent aujourd'hui on peut
laisser la liberté mais en contrepartie
de cette liberté il faut accepter de
payer le prix de la déclaration
bien est-ce que parmi mes collègues il y
a
d'autres questions personne reste sur
frustration
monsieur rapporteur bien madame monsieur
monsieur
le Président Directeur Général d'un DP
merci de nous avoir consacré du temps et
merci de la clarté de votre propos et de
votre éclairage
avec un peu de recul je me dis qu'on
vous aurez peut-être entendu plus tôt il
y a des auditions qui aurait été pour
ceux qui ne sont pas spécialistes plus
clair voilà merci beaucoup